Okay,
Tommy John, Ladies and gentlemen,
how are you sir? I'm fine man.
It's great to see you
again man. You too, Joan.
I tell everybody that one of my first
ever experiences with comedy recordings
was listening to big
bamboo when I was a kid.
My parents had it and uh,
they'd let us listen to it.
We opened it up like a big old packet of
rolling papers and pull out the albums
back then, the actual record, you know?
And so I've been a fan for a long time.
I can tell him, man, I can tell.
How are you the lower the weed? I'm,
I'm fine man.
Couldn't be better.
I'll be 81.
Right.
Wow,
that's amazing.
It sounds crazy to say because I'm 51
that sounds crazy to say. When I say it,
I'm like, Jesus, that true fuck,
I'm 30 years older than you. Wow.
Wow.
That's um, but I feel good man. You
know, all the systems are go again,
you know, and that, that makes a
big difference in the life. Yeah.
That's what I found. The Fountain of
Youth is the Pussy. That's it. Yeah.
That's all it is. Drinker to the phone,
their youth and you'll live forever.
Really? Yeah. Okay. Yeah.
What about if you're gay?
Hmm.
Well, I guess on pause. Yeah,
I had to think about that one.
Wow. I guess it might be Dick for
that, I guess. Shit, no, I don't know.
It has to be the fountain.
It has to be the phone.
So even for gay folks gotta
be Pussy to, well, how long?
What's the longest living gig guide
that you know? That's a good question.
Huh? Like Bob Hope,
man. He was he gay? No,
no. That's my phone to use
because it, sure. Romance. Well,
what happens is your body,
when it reaches a certain stage,
it,
it starts disintegrating because it's
getting ready for the recall in the reboot
and you get a new body
and away you go again.
But if you keep this body healthy,
it feels that there's no need to leave
because he used obviously still got more
shit to do. Yeah. You're still
enjoying it. Yeah. You're
still producing, you know?
Are you exercising and everything?
Oh yeah. Yeah. What do you do?
I've got a trainer now. Yeah.
But my main exercises, tango,
tango, tango, retailer, I
will turn you on to tangle.
Tangle is old folk sex.
You,
you, the whole thing about tango
is it's so intricate. It was a,
the original tango was a mating
dance from Africa, really?
And what they would do, they, the tribes,
a young kids would get together and
dance and flirt with their feet.
And so when the slaves got taken,
you know,
from Africa and put on the boats in that,
the ended up crossing the,
the foot dance with the
Adagio French dance,
the dance of the brothels. And so
the, so then they ended up with a,
uh, a music or a dance called
tangle, which was a combination.
Tango itself is a word
that means small drum.
It's an African drum, just like
mom ball. It's an African word.
That means a storytelling.
Really? Yeah, Dude.
Story time with Tommy Chong
Nail. Yeah, man. I was in jail.
I had nothing but time and I wrote
a whole paper on tango. So anyway,
tangle like I go to Argentina with
my wife a lot and it's very tough.
Dance to dance with your wife,
you have to dance with a stranger
and she has to dance with a stranger.
Why is that? I think it's you're
too intimate, too personal.
You know each other too.
Well, if you're a stranger,
then all you can respond to is the dance,
uh,
signals like the man has to lead,
but he has to lead in such a way that,
that you can't see him. You know,
he can't pull her around the
[inaudible], he suggest, oh, okay.
Like if, and so he'll suggest a
certain movement and the girl,
the his partner will understand that move
and then she can do a couple of steps
and the cer a certain way,
like one is called the, uh,
uh, fuck, I can't remember the,
the term, uh, all chose or chose,
which means back and forth and,
and, and out of those combinations,
once a guy gets a girl going
into the Ochoa's for instance,
then you can move on to,
he'll stop her with his foot and then
you move on to another series of moves.
And they're all designed and,
but the stranger, Eh, you know,
the woman has to really listen to the,
the moves if she's danced
with a stranger or a teacher.
And that's how,
and then it has to be a close embrace and
the woman has to be cuddled up against
the guy. Not always,
but for the most part.
So you're not looking at your feet
at all and it's all about feel.
And so you have to feel the other person's
body and it can get so intimate man
that you really felt after good
dance with a good tango teacher,
you really feel like I happened a
cigarette well and relaxing for a bit.
Did you study this? Did you like take
classes? I got turned onto it in Paris.
I was a chief,
now we're finishing up the
Corsican brothers and I was, we,
we got offered to do the Cisco Kid and
they sent me the script and in the script
said tango dancers.
And so there we,
my wife and I girlfriend at the time,
but the way for now,
we used to drive by this place
that's at tangle in neon lights.
And so we stopped and took our
first tango lesson from this,
uh,
George and Rosie a couple there.
George was too old to get out of bed.
He was in the blood is in his nine
years or something. He was in bed.
Rosie came and met us and we,
and she showed us the first little
bit of tangle while my wife Shelby,
who was an excellent dancer. She's
been studying dance, you know,
ever since. Uh, I can remember,
you know, and so she, she,
she started doing salsa first and then
I'd found out about that and I had to
learn salsa,
but then we started learning tangled
together and then she went on to really
learn how to dance, how to
dance with the prose. Me,
I'm still struggling to be a pro and
it's very hard. It's like MMA fighting,
you know, like she's a pro.
I'm an amateur. And so when I,
when we go down to boiling desires,
like we went down for her birthday, um,
I was the video operator because I
didn't know how to dance, you know, that.
Well, I take lessons
almost, uh, 20 years now,
but it's still don't have the skills to,
to be a professional life
like, like that. But, uh,
yeah. So I went down and videotaped her
and then I came back and I made a vow.
I says, this is embarrassing, you know,
because people know me from years
ago and I still can't dance.
So, so it's, it's about
time that I learned.
So I gave up everything to learn tango
and are willing to give up golf more than
anything. Really. Yeah. There's a lot
of guys right now that are going crazy.
Why would you give up golf for a tango?
Well, actually it worked out really well.
I played a tournament golf, uh, last
week and I did the best I've ever done.
If you lay off something, you forget all
your bad habits. Oh, that's true too.
And you probably will.
I'm really enthusiastic about planning
and loved it and I wasn't. I did good.
I got about two pars. Incredible
for, you know, for me,
I'm, you know, I've got about a 36
handicap, something like that. But uh, so,
but I gave up golf because it's too much
energy was taken too much energy. Sure.
You gotta walk around all the time.
Yeah.
I would also imagine
that the tango dancing,
all the movement in the footwork would
actually probably make you more steady
and stable, balanced, better.
So I'd probably make your
golf game better. Oh, it did.
Totally, totally. I
noticed that with a yoga,
Yoga makes pool better in some weird way.
Like it makes it stands stronger. Yeah.
Yeah. So there's also
a, a pause and comedy.
Someone asked me about the secret
accommodated as a pause in the tangle as
opposed to the timing, the
timing, waiting, waiting,
waiting and using that,
that, that silence, you know,
before you say something to give
people the time to formulate their own
sites about what you're doing or do,
concentrate on what you're going to
say next. And the, and that's the same,
same thing with tango. Is this you? Yeah.
That's me with a PDU. You on dancing
with the stars. Oh, Shit. Yeah.
How hard was that to do? Oh, it's
incredible. [inaudible] or every,
what the hell is going on
here? Good Lord. When he,
same time that we did
it, we did it. We did it.
Wow. Yeah. Rainy, cold drink and a 10,
uh, looked like Randy was crying. Yeah.
What's his name? Uh, Kevin Hart.
Kevin Hart was a judge. Yeah.
He gave me a 10. Oh, that's the
only thing I got. Look at Legos.
She had to carry me
off there. Wow. Oh Man.
That tour my butter.
I imagine literally serious fucking
the training for that. I came off.
That was rectal cancer. Whoa. I got,
I found out on that
show. Wow. How'd you do?
You don't think you got it from dancing?
I always,
I got it from a no smoking and,
uh,
and the stress from no smoking
weed in real smoking weed.
I quit smoking weed during the show.
Why did you do that?
I thought it would help me with my,
uh,
coordination or something like that with
me being there listening, you know? Yeah.
Because it's hard to learn things when
you're styling something that certain
saying, yeah. Like in Jujitsu, uh,
most people agree that it's not a good
idea to smoke pot when you're learning
skills, but it's a good idea to smoke
pot when you have the skills. Yeah. Yeah.
It'll calm you down. Yeah. When you
roll and you already know what to do,
it's like instinctive, then you can
smoke some pot. Yeah. But like learning,
like if someone shows me
a new move and I'm high,
I can't even figure out where the
body's calling McWane. Where's your arm?
How am I doing this? You get too high and
then what am I doing? You get baffled.
Yeah. Yeah. Well that's
the same as tango. Well,
so you really think that that
happened to you because of that? See,
I had prostate cancer and it was a
kind of process was so slow acting.
Lazy ass doctor said,
well, we won't do it.
We'll just leave it alone and you're
probably die of something else before that
happens. And so there's this attitude
that was their attitudes as crop dusters.
Yeah. It happens all the time,
you know, because you know,
prostate can be very slow.
And I had a slow one and black,
I had a biopsy when I had to find out
cause I was going to do the growth
hormone. Uh, and that's why I
checked out my blood to make sure I,
you know, I didn't have cancer
found out I had prostate cancer and,
but they did a biopsy and I think
that could have done it, you know,
the biopsy and they can
be take a piece of your,
so you think that taking a biopsy could
have caused the damage which could have
led the cancer, could have, could
have caused the cancer cell to,
to hit the direct them the way it did.
And so I got a bag now,
I got a clause to me
bag, you know, so, but
no, I'm, I'm totally healed now in,
in, I'm, I'm, I'm good to go. You know,
the only thing,
so I don't know if it was the,
the lack of weed and stress and,
and the fact that I had prostate,
you know,
so when they fixed the
rectal and I got the best,
one of the best doctor could Jay Indian,
what'd they have to do? They had operate,
they had to take out change the
plumbing from the, uh, from the front,
from the back to the front. That's
a colostomy bag. So you, so I,
I have no more rectum.
Wow. So a virgin again.
I'm kidding. And then you put the
bag around to the front and uh,
that's all they did there. And
then I had then, but what they did,
they swept the prostate clean with
the radiation. They said we're,
we're down there anyways,
so we might as well do the prostate to,
so the pics to prostate and thank God I
never had it taken out because now I can,
I got this sleeping giant is a woke again.
Sleeping giant. Yeah. I
woke the sleeping giant of,
I think it was the weed that did it
too, plus my gorgeous weight. But yeah,
I started getting these urges and I
said, Oh, oh, what's happening here?
And I'm doing testosterone and
that's probably what, yeah,
the toss testosterone and then, and then
I'm going in for a shot tomorrow. That's,
it's a,
it's a new procedure that uh,
they use apparently to help induce labor
because it's all about blood flow down
there and so it's going to induce, I
tried pills, I tried Viagra, you know,
doesn't,
doesn't work enough.
And so I'm going in tomorrow for a,
an injection of some,
some help to blood so they help
the giant get a little more awake.
Now when you went to jail, you had
your, you or your cakes was horrible.
I mean it was,
it was so depressing to hear that you
were going to jail for making bongs. Yeah.
It just,
the whole thing was so sick and that they
were threatening to put your family in
jail and then that's all
they sent you to jail.
You couldn't small part for awhile
after that. For years. How long? Um,
probably three years. Because
you're on probation, probation,
pre probation before you went to jail?
Pre, pretrial. Because if you get caught,
vignette ended up getting tortured
while the whole time I was there,
nine months I was there, I couldn't
smoke. They tested me all the time.
They try to catch me and they had nothing
to catch and then a year after that I
was on probation and I never smoked.
I can quit,
you know I got willpower,
you know, I can quit.
I put smoke and I quit drinking.
I quit eating bad for what?
But you had the wreck.
Well for one thing that happened that was
great was that you became even more of
a hero to the cannabis community
because people know, yeah,
you truly were a martyr and then
it was outrageous and it was so,
it was so wrong that even people
that didn't smoke pot really kind of a
fuck you arrest and Tommy Chong like,
come on man.
Like all the terrorists in the world
of criminals and rapists and murderers.
I know you going to put
Tommy John and Joe. Yeah,
like what are we protecting or serving?
What are we doing here? Which one?
Which one is that? Yeah, they were
just showing off, showing off.
But once I sent him a message,
which I got in
the new with a lot of people
that were unjustly incarcerated,
I was in there with the orthopedic
surgeon for the rams and he,
he,
he had been in a tax,
it wasn't legal at the time he did it,
which was that he had a
big car collection and he,
and he rode off the
car collection somehow.
And then the IRS changed people.
And next thing you know, the,
they came to him and said, you all
this money and if you don't pay it,
you gotta go to jail. And he
couldn't pay it. So he went to jail.
This is orthopedic surgeon
and he's like super straight.
The straight is one of the
straightest guys ever met.
And there was another guy that,
that figured out the Oj tax scheme.
You know how old Jay can keep as
money from the hand chain? Thousands
in Florida. Yeah. Well it's a,
it's a law that, a loophole
that allowed, you know,
Oj to keep us taxes. I mean
tax free money. And so,
so this accountant figured out how to
do it and he started getting rich people
so they didn't have to pay taxes.
And so rather than to change the
law or do anything like that,
they just put his ass in jail because he
could and they put them in there for a
year and he wasn't doing anything illegal.
Nothing illegal except,
and then they told them,
or you're going to get out in a year,
but you're not going to do
that tax thing anymore. Wow.
Yeah. No one knows the
government. The IRS is creep. Oh,
do not want to owe them money.
Especially if you're Trump. Oh,
well they're coming after him right now.
Right.
What are they coming after him for now?
They'd like New York state is allowing
Congress to subpoena his tax returns.
Note Your Bank. They got
his accountant, his account.
Nothing to do with the federal government.
I tell everybody,
why would you want to be president?
Like why would you want to do that
to yourself on the sure. Super Clean.
And that even if you're super
clean, they're gonna make
shit up about, you know,
the only reason Trump did it is because
you'll put in so much money. You thanks.
So [inaudible].
Pretty sure.
How did this lose her billionaire get
financed over and over and over again.
And guess who's allowed during money?
Like crazy from Russia,
the guy that needs the money? No, the
whole Trump family is going to go down.
You think so? Oh, pretty sure. Taxes me.
Al Capone to Donald Trump.
You can't evade taxes.
So do you think that he owes taxes?
He owes Putin.
He always Putin so much money that he is
scared to death. How do you know this?
Common Sense. Oh, okay. So it's a
guess or know it figured out. Okay,
let's go down the history.
Uh,
call me is a FBI, right? Uh, Mueller,
the FBI Trump was attacking,
uh,
Obama with the birther Obama's,
the President Obama has got control
over the FBI, CIA, everybody.
So Obama said, okay, find
out about this Trump guy.
So they found out about him.
But the thing is they can't
really do anything on this.
He becomes president. Other than
that, he just walk away free.
No one gives decision, you know,
here's, here's really Brazil anything.
Unless he becomes president.
Yeah. Or You mean the FBI?
There's no breaking the law.
There's no law that says that
you can't deal with Russia.
Only law says you can't deal with Russia
and be the president of the United
States at the same time. The only time
he would break any laws is that if,
if he became president and
he has to become president,
and he became president,
thanks to call me because
Hillary was gonna win,
no matter what they say.
Hillary was gonna win until Komi said,
oh, [inaudible] stuff
came up. And they knew.
They knew back in Obama time that
there was nothing really wrong.
Hillary did nothing,
nothing.
But they told her to release emails
since she deleted 30,000 of them. So,
but she wasn't supposed to do that.
That's illegal.
And she was using her own personal
email server instead of the governments,
which was, it was utter laziness
and convenience. More than,
more than anything illegal.
You know,
she wasn't looking to get financed to
her hotel by the Russians. You know,
she wasn't looking for money. Her and Bill
had money. They got money. Yeah, they,
yeah, they, it's a little fishy little
s little stinkies stuff around there.
But it's normal. It's a, it's a
normal politics. So my theory is,
is that Comey and the FBI said,
let's get this guy.
So you think they let him become
president so they can get them?
I think bars part of the,
part of the, the, the,
the call me gang. This, you know what's
going to be hilarious about this,
this video, when people watch this,
they're gonna go, how high is Tommy?
Tommy challenge made Trump president
so they could prosecute them.
Yeah. Yeah. That's an interesting
theory. Yeah. I don't know if I buy it,
but think about, I don't think anybody's
controlling the strings that well,
but since they papa tears so
that good. But listen, it,
look at everybody that was around
Trump that became chief of staff and
everything else. All military. Right? Why?
Because Trump, Trump's got his
finger on the, on the button.
He's got ability to get on the button.
And so in order to keep him in line,
they got people around him that can keep
them in mind. Yeah. Yeah. And the FBI,
they, they can infiltrate anything.
They infiltrated the mob for years.
They infiltrated the,
the hell's angels.
Do you think they couldn't
infiltrate Donald Trump's gang?
But do you think they were trying to like,
absolutely.
We'll be just because him
going after Obama with the
birther stuff, it's a start.
Yeah. You mess with the
president. Look at that.
And Darby people were saying
he was from Kenya. Right.
There's some ridiculous Photoshop
analysis and his birth certificate.
Anything to keep a black guy
from being a president. Yeah.
And that's what they found out. And,
and the FBI and the federal lives,
you know, against racism.
And that's pretty, pretty,
pretty strict. Pretty heavy,
you know, until Trump got
in and so, so, so anyway,
this is my theory that that does some
gas theory right there. Yeah. Like,
like I, I really feel that Giuliani is,
is part of the scheme to keep Trump,
you know, why was hope? Well, he
gives them hope, you know, hey,
they can't look at your taxes. You're the
president for Christ sake. Uh, you know.
Yeah, you're the supreme
leader. He does have some,
there is some things they won't do.
One year an office,
they won't indict you for certain things
once you're at the office and so they
plan it. We'll look at
Moeller said, he says,
I'm going to hand this off to the
congress. You can impeach him.
Here's all the evidence you need to
impeach him and know the Democrats.
You've got to figure out are we going
to impeach him go through that or are we
just going to go to the election and
beat his ass in the election and then
didn't arrest him after the election?
Who Do you think he's going to beat
him in the election? Anybody? Anybody.
You think Joe time of them? Oh yeah.
Really? Oh yeah, you are higher.
No strong. We, where are you getting
it? Well look at, look at the trunk.
The trunk backers for instance.
Can you find one thinker in that
backing group? Well, I mean,
who are, we were talking about the
same thing. You know, can, can,
can think racism blinds you.
Right?
But what racism, racism is
ignorance. It's a form of ignorance.
I've got her down, I had it in my family,
you know, so I know exactly. I've been,
I've been,
you know,
kissing clothes to racist
and I know that mentality.
And so pure ignorance.
Yeah,
pure ignorance and ignorance
doesn't stop with one thing.
It carries on to a lot a lot of other
things like work and like all sorts of
things. And so when you look at
the people that are opposing Trump,
you know, the, the, the
women, the, the kids,
the intellectuals,
the uh,
the liberals progressive's
all those people they want,
they want a good future for our country.
You know,
the other ones,
they just want to keep everybody
else out or perceived enemies.
It's perceived enemies that anybody,
like anybody with a gun,
that's the whole thing. You know, if you
have a gun, you're not very intelligent.
Why is that? Because you're
paranoid. You're women.
If you have a gun, you're not
intelligent because you're paranoid.
Having a gun means that you're afraid
that someone's going to come in and
attack, you know? Right. And,
and so that having a gun is like, like
they want to arm teachers for instance.
That seemed kind of crazy. Yeah.
That is so stupid. It is so dumb.
You know, just like the ones
that knew or know about guns,
like the cops didn't go into the school.
They knew the guy's got an k,
they're not going to go into that
school with their little pistols.
And so they didn't go into the school.
And the ones that rushed to guide,
they ended up dying.
So what I'm saying is that if you,
if you have a gun at you, if you
think you need a gun for your house,
for whatever,
and if you think you have something
that's where someone else's life,
then you are ignorant. Well, I don't
necessarily think that's what they think.
They don't think that the gun
is worth someone else's life.
They think they don't want to get their
life taken by a homerun mention. Yeah.
Which does happen.
Did you see that video of the guy
that had a raccoon on his boat?
He had a raccoon on his boat. Yeah, he was
saw he packed back any, any and it, no,
it was a wild raccoon.
And he filmed it and he's 20 miles
out to sea and he sees this raccoon.
And so he filmed himself kicking the
raccoon off the boat, into the ocean,
into the ocean.
He filmed it and then he went,
he posted it because he had
no idea how ignorant that was.
Had no idea as the raccoon dangerous.
Was it trying to blacklist you will
fuck you up. We'll fuck you. Sure, sure.
But like the wild. But the wild
guys, the wildlife guy said,
just get a blanket, show it
over and put him in the, in the,
in the bathroom until you close to shore
and then kick them off. Yeah. You know,
but this guy right away, he freaked out
and he's like, this is my cut off my boat.
Terrible way. I'm not going
to die. Well, see that's,
that's a form of ignorance that, that
I'm talking about. It's also just fear.
It's fear. That's what, that's
what fear is. Fear is ignorance,
but if someone has a gun in their
house to protect themselves from home
invasions, home invasions do happen and
people have saved their family with guns.
That's a real thing that you don't read
about that much. Oh, you read about it.
Planning, if you go looking for it, it
really, yeah, there's all my stores.
If you look at the overall,
did they have like a pie chart of
gun violence in this country and an
unfortunately large number is suicides.
And I started talking about how many
people have died, unfortunately,
large number of suicide by gun.
And I feel like if people are going
to kill with a gun, they'd probably
kill them as whole. The pills or anything
else that they had that as well. Right.
And then there's justifiable
homicides by the police. There's,
there's people that are protecting their
house. There's a bunch of different,
these gang violence as a
bunch of different things
that get lumped in when we
talk about gun violence.
But a certain percentage of them are
people that are protecting their house or
their help their, their family from
someone who's trying to hurt them.
It does happen.
Cash I'm in business
with, with uh, with a x,
a pilot from Vietnam and uh,
I'm quite sure you hit,
he has a side arm in his,
his house.
But it would be useless because it's so
locked away and so hidden by the time
anything happened by the time he got to
that gun and got it loaded and found the
ammunition, everything else. Yeah, maybe.
Or maybe he could keep it right by his
bed. No spoken to his house in this,
this one instance.
And then what,
what if it's your daughter or something
coming in late at night and you mistake
her for all,
you open your mouth and say something
possible shooting into the dark or what if
you have a homicide cidal tendencies
and you've been wanting to see the one
thing I learned about guns, cause I
grew up with guns too. I grew up in the,
in the country. And where'd you grow up in
Calgary, Alberta. Canada. Oh really? Oh,
that's right. You're Canadian.
Yeah. Crane. So guns,
guns were thinking about moving
back up there. Oh No, I lived,
I lived up there. Oh No,
I lived there. Oh No, no.
La is where you want to be. But I grew
up with, with, with guns where you,
where you actually needed to gun,
you know, like, especially when the,
when the hawks are coming down
to get your chickens or you know,
some stuff like that.
But I seen the gun culture in,
in, in Calgary and it turned
me off because I seen kids,
they would take a,
a stray dog in time and bring him up to
the field time to a tree or something or
post and then shoot him.
Oh Jesus. Shoot him.
That is sport, you know. Uh, and,
and they couldn't because
here's the thing about guns. Oh,
I went duck hunting with my
brother one time and, uh,
in the field and Acre board
waiting for the ducks to come.
And so here comes a, um, uh, what
do you call it? Is that your phone?
Yeah, I'm sorry. That's okay. I don't
know if you've read, it's out there.
[inaudible] he turned it off. Uh, uh, no,
we went duck hunting and we're waiting
there for hours where the ducks to come
over.
And my brother,
he got bored and there's a
Muskrat swimming across the thing.
So he shot it with a shotgun and he
walks out into the middle of the,
of the slew picks up the most grit
as the ducks flew over top of us.
Just stupidity, man. That's
definitely stupid. But there's
responsible gun owners,
don't you think? Well, let's
see. Are like, all right. I,
I was in army cadets and when we,
we had practice, I'm a, I'm a,
I'm a sharp shooter by the way.
Yeah, yeah. I got some, some,
what do you call it? Patches, you
know, sharp shooter, uh, 300 yards. So,
so I,
I know how to handle a rifle anyway,
but when we would go shooting,
we would have to,
first of all,
we never got the weapon and until we
marched down into firing position than we
were handed the weapon.
And one bullet and then we
put the bullet in the target.
And another bullet. Shoot the target.
And then when we were finished,
we had to pick up all our
casings and give them back.
And if anything was missing, no one left
until they found that missing bullet.
And that's gun safety.
Yeah.
Then the gun was taken from
us and put it in an armory.
It's only used when you're
going to use it, you know,
it's just like walking around
with a skill saw. You know,
you can have a license to carry a skilsaw,
but you don't have a skilsaw strapped to
your side and you can take out and try
your skilsaw anytime you want. And this
is the open carry thing is very strange.
Let me see. People walking around with
guns strapped to their hips in Arizona.
You're like, okay, they're
targets. Why don't you do
that? You're a target in a way.
Yeah. It's like the bikers, bikers,
you know the hell's angels and the Mongols
in that nearly go. Only in Synagis.
I know that that advertise
on their back.
Look at me. Yeah. Look at me. I'm
a thug. I'm a, you know, I extort,
I do all sorts. I beat
up people, I kill people.
Aaron and I write on a big Hog,
you know? I mean it's crazy.
But people do that for recognition.
Yeah. See that's what like mass shooters,
that's what they do at four.
Get their name in the paper and look at,
I did look at useless. Sold me
on the side. So utilization.
What's the craziest thing about mass
shooters as it's not a threat? I mean,
guns have been around for a long time,
but this is not a thing that's
been around for a long time. Now.
This is a fairly recent thing that keeps
erupting over and over and over again.
I didn't know you were too young
to remember, but when I was a kid,
the crime comics were band.
You're a band.
They were banned because they were bad.
They showed violence despite
books. Comic books. Wow.
And they were people up in arms about
comic books and now you got video games.
Where were you going to be a mass killer?
Well, how about movies? You know, I mean,
so many movies. So these John Wick
movies, it's everybody's getting shot.
Everybody by one of my favorites
to peppermint with permit.
What's up Jennifer Gardner?
I've just seen that.
Oh, what did I get? Oh, she's a
superhero. Oh. Or, or peppermint.
The name of the is peppermint and
here are the Sammy, you're out
or something.
Not that long
ago. Yeah. That's great. I
watched it about three times now.
And the, yeah. Why have you
watched it so many times?
I think Jennifer Garner was kind of hot.
Oh, okay. And in this year to see her,
to see her with the guns in there.
And the third time I realized a
lot of it were stunt stunt people.
How can you tell? Just, I seen
it so many times. It wasn't jobs.
You're looking for everything.
I'm looking for that little thing.
But again, that's the kind of
violence that we get shown.
And people get him immune. Yes.
And especially, especially,
uh, people, they get stupid.
You know, like when I was a kid,
I saw my brother died recently
and there's a whole picture,
a photo thing of him and I when we were
kids and they used to get put under the
Christmas tree, six guns. And
we're, when we're little guys, we,
we're three or four years old.
I had six gun strapped to my myself,
you know,
because the cowboys,
Lord Rogers and Gene Audrey.
And that was a big deal. You know,
you had your six gun shooters,
but you never shot anybody. You just shut
the gun out of their hand, you know? Sad.
That was the old days. Yeah, right.
The good guys always shot people in the
hand that shot the gun away from him.
You gotta be like, all
right, you got me. Yeah,
definitely. World. Yeah. It does.
Going from the old days to big
bamboo to where we're at today,
where you're actually in the weed business
now. Oh, you know what, John's choice,
which is crazy, right? It's like you
were arrested for just selling glasses.
How many years ago was that?
Like 15 1303 oh three 16 years ago.
16 years ago, you were arrested for just
selling glass, 2019 yourself full on.
We'd, we'd be in four or five
countries. That's crazy. Germany,
Spain. You can, you were so
ahead of the curve. Yeah.
But you also, you were one of the
real ogs that paid a price. Yep. Yep.
And you know,
now it's gotta be nice to see that your
influence had something to do with all
this. It did. It feels really well.
Really, that's all your movies. I mean,
you guys made, we'd look fun.
Yeah. Yeah. It was fun. Yeah.
But everybody made it out
like a, you know, you go from,
if you think about propaganda, positive
and negative, you go from reefer madness,
which is the most negative to
the Cheech and Chong movies,
which is probably the most positive,
most positive up until like half baked.
That was the most positive
we'd stuff we ever saw. Right.
It was so super positive. It was all
just silly. Yeah. Fun, crazy, crazy,
silly, uh, humor, ghetto humor. You know,
a lot of ghetto humor and, and,
and I want it to be the rich guy.
You know the kid of the rich guy cause
that's what the 60s happen, you know,
all the hip, you know, in order to
get laid you had to be a hippie.
So all the rich kids growing their
hair long and you know, through,
you know, living on the streets,
all that stuffs. Yeah. Yeah.
You guys a popular as vans too and we,
you know, yeah. You know we used to,
we used to say when we'd be on the radio,
some of the radio shows and I,
and I was really popular on right wing
radio shows cause I would inflame the
whole, you know, pissed
off at me as I went out.
People like Danny Sullivan,
you know the race car driver.
I said Oh yeah, Danny smokes pot
and people got mad at you for that.
All went nuts.
I think that's why I got busted because
I was in Saint Louis on a radio show
that ash crop listened to.
And I think Ashkar I've heard me and the
hit window people forgot how crazy that
guy is still alive.
That's a good question.
But do you remember when he was singing?
He had a song that he sang that he
wrote about let the eagles soar.
This is when,
yes,
when he was attorney general and it was
so creepy and crazy that this person
would say he had a whole album of of
Gospel music. Like he was us. Sigh.
Oh,
it was,
I would love to climb inside that guy's
head and find out what kind of gears are
spinning around in there.
I think I did.
I think I ended up in jail
for my pro forma thing.
Yeah. He had a whole song that he sang on
television. He said, I think he sang. It
was either front of Congress or something
along those lines where he know he was
giving a speech somewhere and then along
with the speech he wanted to sing the
song,
let the eagles soar like
she's never sword before.
It's so they want to hear it save you
fight at Jamie. It's, it's so bad.
10 seconds from a daily show moment
of Zen that they did with it.
Well this is a v the video
is that video look shitty.
This is the clearest for you.
I could fuck it up quick.
It's just 10 seconds of it. Okay. Here's
the, here's the video. Look at this.
Check this out.
Look up there.
Oh,
like she is never slow.
Ooh.
From a rocky coast stop. That's
all you need to see. Like stop.
You can't nothing forever,
Bro.
Nobody knew. That's when you kind of
see. Yeah, maybe guns or, okay, yeah,
maybe everything's fine. Maybe
missiles, but seeing the guy like that,
thinking that that psychopath had any
control whatsoever over any laws or anyone
getting arrested.
That guy is fucking insane.
He's the guy who was wanting to cover
the breasts on statutes. Yes. Yeah. Hey,
did which broad tension to
them? Yeah. No one noticed it.
Titch before he put a veil
over. Exactly. Then now they're
looking at the RUC as titties. He was a
spooky guy and he was your wallet. Yeah.
I found out over Bush administration
had some spooky fucking people there.
They really did.
It's really interesting that history
whitewashes these weird old guys. Yeah,
like Ronald Reagan.
After he died,
Ronald Reagan became like this patron
saint of conservative thinking.
When I was in highschool,
Ronald Reagan was president and everybody
fucking hated that. They hated them.
It was like he was a creep thought
about, I'm like, this guy's a fraud.
He's a phony. He's lying about selling
arms to Iran. The whole thing was,
it was, it was so crazy to watch
that guy become this loved figure.
I used to work out with his daughter,
Patty Raelynn,
and her and I were pretty good friends
until one day it came to the gym and I
saw part of a movie called Colliculi Leah.
And she said,
oh, how did you like it? I said, I was
too faggy for me. And apparently Ron,
her brother, her brother's very gay
and she blew it. She, oh, up at me.
How do, how can you say that? How dare
you, don't, you know my brother. And
Yeah. So it's nothing to
do with the movie, just,
you know, I'm not into that and that's
okay. I just don't like watching it.
It doesn't mean I don't want you
to do it. That's funny. Yeah.
Ron was like super hardcore
Democrat, right. And son it was,
that was an interesting little thing.
Yeah. So that his son was gay. Uh,
Ronnie was, wasn't that
right wing and until, uh,
until he found a better path for
him. Like Trump. Yeah. He was, uh,
Ronnie was a Democrat like
Trump. Yeah, yeah, yeah. He
was when he was younger. Yeah.
See when they get older, you know,
then that's, that always happens.
All sell your share. Annoyed. Yes.
They also get paranoid and they start
wanting to tighten up the borders and
walking load.
Let the [inaudible]
she's never saw before.
And imagine like sitting down,
writing that out and then,
and then singing it with all that
emotion and passion as if that makes any
fucking sense to animal. Well,
obviously no, there was no
stopping him. You know,
he's a fucking moron.
And the song's about a bird that's
an evil repped like a raptor.
Like any eagle was a fucking
monstrous animal will eat babies,
they'll eat anything they
can get their hands on.
They swooped down and snatched fish, ran
a fucking river. They're fun. I mean,
they're amazing creatures. I don't hate
eagles, but the idea that that's America,
America is a fucking vicious flying
dinosaur. It's kind of hilarious.
It really is kind of hilarious.
That's our animal. Uh, funny. No,
I pissed off a lot of people and you know,
yeah.
Not Meaning to say, you know, we used
to say when they would attack us,
you know,
what if we're right,
what if everything we're doing
is right and you're wrong.
And next thing you know it's
true. We were right. Yeah.
But you were right the whole
time. Yeah. And you know,
I remember when I first started
smoking weed, I was, well,
I had smoked it a couple of times up
until I was 30 and then when I was 30,
my friend Eddie, Eddie Bravo got me
high for the first time. I remember,
I couldn't believe that this was
what pot was. I was like, this is it.
I thought it made you stupid. I call, I
can't stop thinking about things like,
yeah, some of the thoughts are a little
on the organized and kind of chaotic,
but it wasn't making me lazy.
It wasn't doing any of these things
that people were claiming it did,
didn't make me stupid.
It made me curious. Yeah.
Made me want to watch science
documentaries and eat. Yeah,
and dance and eat and it tasted so good.
I can't believe I'm good.
This food tastes,
I know it's just to,
it is one of the biggest puzzles of
modern times is that even in 2019 with all
these states that have legalized it,
there's still a bunch of people that
think that pot is bad for you and then it
makes you lazy. And I always say
that pot is like any other tool.
It's like a hammer.
You could build a house with a hammer
or you can just hit yourself in the Dick
if you're fucking crazy.
And it's the same thing with pot that's
exactly can use pot and you can enhance
your life and it can enhance
your relationship and it
makes you friendlier and
more calm, more comradery,
more compassion.
Or You could just get stoned
all day and do nothing.
You got that Goddamn phone ringing on
your roof. Does that freak you out?
Have Enough? I had one of those on
my breasts for a day and I was like,
what am I doing? I don't, I
don't know how to work it,
so it's just decoration for me.
Why do I have a regular watch?
That funny saying that your son got
up before me. There's various. Got It.
Because he, he updates my
everything. Oh, okay. Okay.
If it wasn't for parasites and still
be you riding a bike. Yeah. I don't,
I don't,
I had one of those that I was using for
a while for like fitness tracking stuff.
Then I got this,
whoop,
I got this other thing that's quite a
bit more accurate and does more stuff.
You're 51 51. Yeah. Good
shape, man. Thank you. Dumb,
scared.
Never let it go.
I work on all the time because I'm
terrified of it falling apart. Well, no,
you're hooked on the adrenaline and you're
hooked on the endorphins, friendship.
But yeah, with that too, it's also for
mental health reasons. Like for me,
I need to, oh, I got a size, well,
like Arnold, you know, when I,
when I first came to La, I, I uh,
personally I did was join the Gold's
gym cause I read about it, you know,
in Vancouver. And then I met Arnold
and all the, all the guys in there,
there were so healthy, you know,
if he took a sip of seven up,
you'd spit it out. Really? Yeah.
And he was a super, super healthy,
but he smoked a joint. He was smoking
a joint. That was another thing,
pumping iron. That documentary palm
parents saw him after he won. Yes.
Smoking a joint.
I made the pot look like, wow, this guy
smoked pot. Right. How the fuck is pop?
Make you a loser if the
biggest body builder
on the planet, the most successful
yes. Six far guy. Yeah. Yeah.
I owed him one time,
like I owed everybody and,
and Arnold was walking was Stallone at
the time and there's that famous picture.
Yeah, they ass this numero uno.
They asked Arnold, uh, you know,
Tommy Chong said that he smoked pot with
you and Stallone jumped in right away
or no, that's a lie. That's
a lie. You ain't never smoked
in order, so no, no. Yeah,
we did smoke, but we knew how
to enjoy ourselves back then.
The loan, I'm trying to cover it up
while he can still own this, to the loan.
Those Rambo movies. Oh, I got
some good stories on Stallone.
But you don't remember Jordan Belfort?
Jordan Belfort,
the wolf of Wall Street? Yes.
Yeah, I was in jail with him. Oh,
I helped him write his book.
Really? Yeah. In fact we're,
all I did was insult him and made him
write his book cause I was reading my book
and he was started, he said,
what are you doing and writing,
cause we shared a cubicle and I said,
I'm ready. My book. He says, Oh,
I'm going to write a book.
And so he wrote a couple of pages and
he handed it to me like, Hey, read this,
you know, and it read it and it was
like a copy of Tom Wolfe, you know,
bonfires in the manatees. And I
said, you haven't written shit.
Handed it back to him. And
he says, what do you mean I
haven't written nothing. He said, what
should I write? You challenged me. I said,
write what you know. I says, right.
Those stories you've been
telling me or be night, you know,
he said there's one rule that you've
got to remember when you're writing or
doing anything,
it's called the most of so you don't get,
you don't just get high,
you get higher than anybody's
ever gotten in their life.
If you're going to put it on screen,
you know, you don't just have a fight,
you have a fight that goes
on forever, you know, that's,
that's the kind of stuff you need
that people are interested in.
And so he said you didn't talk to me for
both but a month after that and he was
mad at you. Yeah. He was just
right now shoulder scar and he,
and he wrote the wolf of
Wall Street. Well, yeah.
And then he give it to you in the like,
all right, you got something here? No, no,
no, no, no. The last time,
the next time I saw him,
he pulled in front of
my house with his car.
We were both on probation so
we couldn't talk to each other.
And so he yelled from his car.
He goes, Hey, I sold them,
sold the book to a Martin Scorsese.
So you're allowed to talk to
each other by yelling. Yeah.
But you couldn't be close. Yeah. You
couldn't be close. Did you have to,
how far away do you have to stay loud?
You know,
technically you're not supposed to
talk to each other, you know, but,
but yelling there, no one's
gonna say anything about
this. Hilarious. Yeah, no, no,
you can,
you violate your probation.
They put you back in jail because you're
associating with felons. That's right.
Right.
That's,
that's so crazy that someone who
you're trying to rehabilitate with. No,
you can't talk to them
because they also fucked up.
There was a Nixon speech writer that was
in with me and he was so innocent and
they want,
and what the government was trying
to get stuff on Amelda Marcos in the
Philippines and this lawyer that I
was in there with a speech writer,
a Reagan speech writer,
and,
and he wouldn't give up Marcos or Amelda.
And so they put him in jail for a year.
And when he got out on probation,
being a straight guy, he was, he went
home and took a Valium to help him sleep.
And he got drug test at the next day.
He went back in jail. He wouldn't,
he went back baggage Joe.
So you've gotta be very careful when
you're dealing with probation people cause
they got you by the
balls. Man. I had such a,
it's gotta be a weird thing dealing with
the probation officers cause they have
that power on you. Did
they fuck with you? Not me.
I was too much of a celebrity and I had
a lot of Nice ladies and so I'd flirt
with him. And you know, friends. Yeah,
service area thing. [inaudible] I'm sure.
Like all things right. There's good
people doing it and bad. Oh yeah. Yeah.
It's a job. It's a job.
It's a paycheck. You know,
the sad thing about when I was in jail
at Taft was that it's built over a toxic
waste dump where they used to,
that's where they found
oil in tab in California.
And when they found oil back in the day,
they never had a way to contain it.
They would just dig it, he hit it and it
would just spilled all over the ground.
And so they would dig big trenches out
big pools and they would fill up with
oil. Then they would get the
barrels and dip the barrels in.
And that's how they filled
up the oil barrels. And,
and so after the figuring out
how to do it right, they, uh,
the ground is all toxic.
And so they built a federal
prison over top of it.
And so everybody that's worked there
and a lot of people that did time,
they're all gotten cancer and died.
So he think that's probably the root of
your cancer? Could be. Could be. Could be.
He's sure. Yeah. Easy. Yeah.
Cause that's where I got it.
And they say that marijuana
does something to cancer, right?
Inhibits cancer in certain ways.
I don't know technically what it does.
I think what it does more than anything,
it calms the brain seeing
anytime you calm the brain,
you lose a fear.
So you know,
the fear is that fight or flight,
you know, that's your response.
Your body goes into this
fight or flight mode.
And when you calm that down,
your body just goes into relaxation mode.
And when you're in the
fight or flight mode, uh,
the other parts of your body can't,
can't function properly
like your immune system.
But when you're totally relaxed mode,
that's why when a animal gets hurt,
they usually just crawl off in a corner
somewhere and just lay there and lick
their wounds and they
just calm everything down.
And then they let the
body take over to heal.
And I think what happens with pod is it,
it mellows the brain to the point where
you, yeah, so what you know, and you,
you allow your body to take over,
but you still need that other treatments.
You still need the chemo,
the radiation, you need
all that stuff, you know?
Are you taking CBD oil now? Yeah.
Oh yeah. Yeah. How much do you take?
I'm not sure. I'm not good at that
amount. You know. [inaudible] good.
I take it, I have it right now.
I'm on testosterone and uh,
and CBD. Yeah. And then
just power, you know,
smoke up over a couple of joints or we've
got a, we've got a gift bag for you.
Yes. Thank you. Yeah. Thank you.
Thank you. So he's going to
have it. I got some for be real.
It scared the shit out of me. I
did be real smoke box. Oh yeah.
Be Real from Cypress. Yeah, I know.
But that's probably as high as
I've ever been in my life. Really.
Those guys go hard. Oh yeah. I
couldn't keep up with him. No, no.
I don't even try.
I'm a lightweight man.
When I spoke with Arnold Wa,
all Dave draper,
all these muscle heads would come
around and they get a big bong.
And the thing was they put like a,
like a,
an ounce in the bowl and then they'd
fired up and then they suck on it so hard.
Whoever exploded the bowl into the,
into the water made it explode.
Then you are the hero. It's, uh,
all the, all the muscle ads
there, they're taking their hit.
Arnold takes a big hit, you know, the
thing explodes. Then they handed to me.
It was like,
they looked at me like no
with the Chong at the time.
So they just looked at me like, yeah,
okay, go sell where there's Dan.
You were just a guy. Yeah, I was
just winning. Almost faceless.
What was it like being famous for
being a pothead back in the 70s?
Cause that'd be weird as you were,
you were,
you and Cheech were famous potheads where
I don't think there was anybody else.
Like who else was a famous
pot at no water level?
Uh, no, no one, not, no one ever
spares. Same, uh, the actor.
Oh Christ. I can't think
of his name. He did time.
He did a year in jail in county
for one joint. Robert Mitchum.
Oh yeah, Albert Michonne. But he was like
a straight laced guy. Yeah. The image.
Big Cowboy. Yeah. Yeah. He got high. He
lived to tough guy that does the image.
Well, you know what the big, the big, uh,
draw for pot was the sex.
See it?
Uh, it was, it was before, what
do you call the supers are,
uh, so parkway Lids, you know,
the Courtland thing and equate
lewd was big sex things that was a,
people would have sex on
Queloz. Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
I've never taken it quite a bit.
What does it do for you? Oh, just it,
they're called
when a girl gets high on, on, on
a coil. Ludas like take me. Yeah.
Do you think that's why bill Cosby was
the girls will quote? Totally. Totally.
So that was the thing that just relaxes
you and it makes you horny, really?
Oh yeah.
And that's what pot does for me now,
but it does for people, for women,
Women Loeb do sleep with that.
And they loved to have a six,
you know, after smoking a joint,
where was Annie Hall was in
Annie Hall with woody. Xy End.
He got a little pissed off.
Do you have to get high every
time you make love with me?
Yeah. All that sobriety,
is that any hall?
I think it was Annie Hall and I think,
I think everybody in the picture, the
movie company, the Movio said yeah,
I could dig it.
Yeah.
It definitely changes the way things
feel. Yeah. Relaxes. Yeah. Axis.
You hear music so you feel things better.
Everything feels nice here. You know,
I like to do yoga on it. I like to smoke
weed right before I go to yoga class.
Yeah. That's amazing. Yeah.
I feel all the muscles filling all the
tiny ones and the ones connected to your
spots and you don't smoke a lot.
Or do you a couple of talks or before
yoga class? I don't want it too high.
I'll just be inside my head. Yeah. I
just wanted like two heads just hits.
Just going, hi, I'm high,
but I'm not blasted. Yeah,
that's me too.
I got a,
I've been giving all sorts of toys, you
know, cause I got the Chungs choice.
We in the stores in the,
and so the,
I'm getting tons of pipes all the time
and I make pipes to in fact that that's
the not a pipe. This is another one of
those. I you go last I got one of the,
okay, last time was like six,
whatever it was six years ago.
Last time you were on the show. Yeah,
he gave me the nod of pipe. Oh good.
I got it at home but I, you
know, so, so now they got,
they got a new one.
Can't think of it.
I got it for you here and
you go, oh great. Thank you.
It's called easy pipe. Oh,
okay.
Easy.
But it's so cool because you open the
thing and it's got a lighter built in and
there's a,
just a,
a enough doubles holds enough for a
little nugget but nugget in there and you
can carry it in your pocket cause there's
a lid and then when you're one on one
a hit it,
you just hit the later,
you got to hit Ah,
one of those before.
And I was like a little metal lid.
Slides over to the side. Yeah,
those are pretty cool. Oh yeah. They're
very nice. Yeah. Nice little contraption.
All contained. Well, the old ones,
hitters used to be chunks choice right
there. Compile yet. That's a challenge.
Oh, that's the different thing
about the genius pipe. Ah, yes.
Incredible. Incredible. What does
that do? Well, it cools the smoke.
She from the bowl to the,
to the mouthpiece is the most piece.
The whole thing is, is, is dimpled inside.
And so the smoke goes through all
this, the dimples and cools. It.
Cools it off. You sorta like
ice water and a bong. Yeah.
Yeah. Better. Better, better.
Oh it's, it's so smooth now. I'll
cough it. Just thinking about it.
But you do the genius pipe
and it's just so cool.
Do you get all these kids that are
Dabbin and using wax and I watch,
do you ever go to Cypress hills?
Instagram page? I get fucking,
I get anxiety just watching their videos.
Like how high you get in,
cause they play.
I want to get high.
So high. And you're watching the
video and you're like, oh my God,
I can't do this. I can't
even watch this. I know.
Scooping that yellow wax in there and
you know, they go, they go so deep.
These kids today,
none of their fucking mind are heating
up glass and dropping the THC into the
glass. Like I was at one when dispensary
tree and the guy was so proud,
he handed me a big jar of shatter,
you know,
the stuff in. I pretended
like, oh, it's a gift. Oh,
things and put in those bugs in her,
walked away.
The guy is both of truck.
That was probably a lot of money
through that stuff or lose.
It was like a year's worth of debt.
Oh my God.
And I kept it long enough to
make him nervous. And then,
you know,
with Canada we had
deal with hash a lot. Uh, and it's okay,
but it's a little bit too
harsh. Caches. Harsh. Yeah.
The highs. Interesting though. Yeah.
Yeah. It's a, it's an intense high. Yeah.
What do you, how do you feel about
edibles? I love him to sleep on.
I love the chocolate.
I got you is what my wife and I both use.
Oh yeah.
We'll wake up in the middle of the night
instead of fussing and fighting or you
know,
thinking about it.
We just go and get a little
little chocolate thing.
It's delicious chocolate too.
It's deficiency chocolate in it's
suppressing and you just sleep.
Not only I slept last night,
but I had a couple of them pivot
epiphanies that just blew my mind.
And how art is going to save the world.
Art is considered the world.
Yeah. How's that? Well,
you look at history like the pyramids,
that was art.
That was an art piece.
And what happens when you,
when you have big huge
art pieces like that,
you create employment and it's not war.
So you're not fighting,
you're creating. And so
the people that, that uh,
share for the animals,
the people that have to feed the,
the mass of people that have to work on
getting those rocks, carbon, those rocks,
everything else, it creates employment
in, it also creates tourism.
And so you, when you have
piece of art, everybody
wants to come and look at it. And so
that's what we need in the world today.
You see? And we not only need art, but we
need functional art because that's what,
uh, the pyramids were. They
were functional and a lot
of people think it was the,
uh, the astronauts in
aliens. Aliens, which,
which could very well be. Yeah. Really
think so. Oh sure. For sure. For sure.
Why do you think that? Why? Because
there's nothing new in the universe.
You know? [inaudible] we've had space
flights. We've had all that stuff forever.
But you have Tom's choice. Cooler
pipe. Yeah. That genius pipe.
That's a new in the universe. That's,
that's, no, that's probably rehashed.
I was somewhere and Rehab someone.
Yeah. So, no. So in the University, oh,
you talk about,
or you want to talk about pot to Chinese,
Indian shorts, all, all religions.
What makes you think that aliens built
the parents though? I kind of same.
They could have been really,
I think aliens are just humans.
You know that because if they're
wearing space suits, they're aliens.
Why did they need a space suit on
this? He did come from another, uh, uh,
atmosphere.
I personally believe that earth is
the only planet in this universe.
And the reason I believe that is that
there are countless universities like
spaces endless.
And so spaces in this why,
why wouldn't we have our own universe?
Okay.
So you think that earth is the
only planet in this universe? Yes.
But what about Mars? Oh,
that's a dead planet. Okay.
So earth is the only live planning.
The only time with life in
this whole universe. Yeah.
So you think that there's multiple
universes are infinite numbers of
universities in each universe
probably has an earth or too or too.
But you think this whole universe of
hundreds of billions of galaxies. Yeah,
it's with hundreds of
billions of solar systems.
Could be there's only one planet. Could
be. Cause we have the space. So the only,
you mean by one planet. One planet with
life. Yes, but we're intelligent life.
But why wouldn't you think that there's,
cause it's so big.
Why wouldn't you think that there could
possibly be other life, other places?
Why couldn't it be the other
way? Why couldn't we be the
only ones that could be?
That's what I'm saying. We totally could
be so, so there's no reason for me. See,
see, that's the way I have trouble with
people that are afraid of Ai. You know,
artificial intelligence. Yeah.
I think so silly because why?
Because they're smart.
They're smart enough to know that
they're not going to him slave anybody or
torture anybody or take over anything.
Not only dummies, do that stuff,
you know? Because when you
capture something, you know what?
You capture their problems,
whatever their problems are,
US extinguish them. Yeah.
For what reason? Well,
that people are just destroying the earth.
They're polluting the rivers.
They're sucking all the fish
out of the sea. It's not,
the guy's filled with carbon
there. The artificial lives
can be like, you know what?
The real problems he's gotten them people,
their dirty little litters.
They're choking squirrel.
See, that's the paranoid. Look at
it. Look at the positive again.
What's the positive? Well, first
of all, you have to remember,
we live in a physical universe.
Okay?
For every action there's a reaction.
So for every good,
there's a bad,
nothing explains Trump more than
for every Obama, there's a Trump,
you know what I'm saying?
Okay.
So there's no limit to how ignorant you
can be and there's no limit to how smart
you can be.
There's no limit.
And so when you go up the
skill intelligence skill,
then,
then you realize that there's no reason
to be paranoid about anything because
it's all written out. I know all the
holy books written it out, you know,
especially the Bible.
See the Bible has been misconstrued by
so many people because what they do,
they'd take it to what's going
to suit their purposes and that,
but to really interpret the Bible,
it's written in code.
It's written. It's a secret code
of, yeah, it's metaphysical terms.
It's not physical terms
of metaphysical terms.
What do you know about the
Bible and cold look wouldn't,
there's a writer called Emmet
Fox should get into him.
Yeah, he, he deciphers the whole Bible.
Does he decipher the ancient
Hebrew version of the Bible
or the Greek version of
the Bible? Latin verse in the Bible.
All the versions. Right. But I mean,
it all comes from ancient Hebrew.
And when you translate things from
ancient Hebrew, this ancient Hebrew,
the letters also double as numbers.
Sure.
And, and, and, and see. See w w w
the people I read, there's another
mistake that I read a lot.
Mystic, mystic, you know,
or you know,
he's not he,
but his name is Joel s Goldsmith.
I discovered him a long time ago,
but I discovered him in jail.
It's a very popular book in jail and
Goldsmith look him up. He's all on the,
on the computers and everything
else. Check him out. You'll really,
really enjoy it. It'll give me a
new perspective because what he,
he maintains, it's all written
in, like I say in the Bible,
eternity. Let's see. There's
no beginning and no end.
That explains everything to me because
if there's no beginning and to know and
what can,
what can happen will happen.
You know?
And because this,
again, this is my, my, my
theory is in the physical world,
we have to learn everything.
That's why everything's physical.
Like the first thing when you're born,
you have to learn how to breathe.
You have to learn how to, you
have to learn how to eat. The,
these are all skills that you have to
literally learn and mothers and everything
teach you you that. And then
when you reach a certain age, uh,
you leave the planet, you know,
they're at least your soul,
your spirit and the body, the body
stays. But it's just a vehicle.
And so because of eternity,
this goes on and on and on and on forever.
It never stops.
What we do as humans, we're learning.
We're, we're creatures of we're,
we're all students whether we
want to be or not. You know, I,
I was trying to explain this to my one
side because my youngest son is a bit,
he's a musician, you know, and, and I,
and I try to understand that he's
a musician and, uh, you know,
musicians aren't that, uh, you know,
they're not as entrepreneurial as as
some people would like them to be.
But anyway,
everybody's here to learn a certain task.
And some of us are blessed to
the point. Like me, I'm blessed.
I'm very blessed because,
uh,
I've been given the ability to do what
I do and to see what I see and to say
what I say. You know, it doesn't come
from me. It comes from, you know,
the source,
what I call the source.
And that's why I could turn prison into
a religious retreat because it's like a
monk going, you know, into
hiatus for, for nine months.
You just had a thought in your head
that you're going to treat it like a
religious retreat and you'd learn
about yourself and educate yourself,
read all the books,
take advantage of your solitude because
that's very important when you get a
chance to be alone,
man,
that's very important time because that's
when you connect with the, the, the,
the spiritual. You're
spiritual teacher. How must've,
it must've felt so good
to be released though
in a way. There was a lot of
sadness really. Yeah. Yeah.
I never looked as good as
when I got released, man. Uh,
one of the it because one of the
inmates there who was a barber,
he spent two hours cutting my hair.
Perfect.
Is a Chicano know it just perfect.
I come out, my wife shall,
we looked at me. Whoa, that's
the best haircut you've ever had.
Everything was, it was perfect.
We exercise it in jail. Oh,
that's all you do.
You walk at night,
there's a track and you can walk miles
around the track in the whole prisons out
there walking around,
walking around.
That's when you socialize and talk
and everything else to people in the,
and they all grouped
together and I learned games.
I learned how to play Bocce ball learn.
I played pool and I sang.
I had a little area where I
had my own private studio.
It was an entrance to the pool hall
and I'd sit in there and the echo was
perfect. You guys had a pool hall? Oh
yeah. We had tennis courts, pool halls.
Great time.
It was
telling you other than
not being able to leave,
and even then if you when to
leave, I'm going, why would
you want to leave? I mean,
it was perfect, so he didn't,
that's why people go back to jail.
Totally get released. Only, I saw
one guy who was sad, he was crying,
but he should be in there crying.
I said, what's wrong? He's,
he gets released next month and he was
a junkie and he knew that as soon as he
hit the street, he was going
to die. He was going to die,
you know. And he did. He,
as soon as he hit the street, he
died. But he was funny. He was,
they had a little game that when
they opened the dormitory, uh,
the first few people to hit the mess hall
got to order eggs any way they wanted,
like over easy or sunny side up, whatever.
And so he'd be, he'd get all anxious.
He'd be the first guy in line and
you'd be kind of getting ready,
getting ready to sue the doors opened.
Man. He'd do, and you couldn't run.
You had a walk. And so you learn that
fast. It had walked real fast and,
and you, he was, he was a
delight. But when he got released,
he took his own life.
So yeah,
I hung was on life with heroin or
probably, yeah, that's probably, it was,
it was sad. He just couldn't help
himself. Wants, no. Well, see, you know,
everybody's worried about socialism.
Well,
America's biggest socialist
country in the world. Yeah.
We've got more people in jail than
anywhere else in the world. And what's,
what did what, what happens in
jail? Cradle to grave. You're fed,
you're close. You're told what
to wear. You're told what the uh,
W two,
you're allowed to study certain things.
You're totally controlled medical.
You got free medical there.
There were prisoners
that would go to jail,
so they get their open heart surgery
because the federal law mandates that if
you have something wrong with you,
they have to fix it.
And so there were prisoners that would
break the law so they could get in to get
their open heart surgery.
Wow. Yeah. That's crazy, man.
That's some next level thinking.
Yeah.
I want to go to jail so I can get open
heart surgery. Yeah. Yeah. What did,
what did they prevent you
from reading any books?
Was there anything that was like on,
could you order whatever you wanted? They,
they had a endless weird,
they had a thing about, uh,
they would take covers off magazines and,
and you know,
the wine subscription cards,
they would take that out because people
on the outside with dosen with the acid
LSD and shipped the books in there.
And then next thing you know,
half a dorm would be tripping on acid
cause they're eating pieces of the
subscription paper paper. Yeah. And
that, that kind of stuff always went on.
But as far as, uh, now you can read
whatever you want it basically, you know,
I read a lot of books at it,
you know,
I was meaning to read, you know,
and I helped a lot of people. Uh,
I would do the teaching, you know,
the change. I would do the itching,
you know how to do that on
the Indian grounds. Oh yeah.
Yeah. It's a really easy,
yeah. Throw the coins. It's
really heads tails. You know,
it's supposedly, it's some sort of
a like future reading. Yeah. Thing.
Do you think it works? Oh yeah. What
does the tire, well, first time I did it,
I roll it. I did my explain to people
how it works. Well, what it is,
you get three coins and and you,
you throw the three clients in it and
you get numbers from six to nine and
anything in between, six,
seven, six, eight, nine.
I think this suddenly that, anyway, uh,
each number tells you what line you're
going to read in Utero it three times and
you write down and then you get a
sort of like a, a plan of where,
what page you're supposed to look at.
And then when you get the page,
uh, then it tells you, you know, but,
but you're asking it because you've
got to ask the eating for what per,
if something, you know,
and it'll answer it,
it'll answer you as for instance,
I threw mine when I did it.
I threw it in the first line,
said you are in jail for a reason.
Whoa. How does it say that? It just
said it when it says it. How was it?
What do you translate it?
You read it.
It's been written in that book for
centuries. That line is in the,
in that book for centuries, really,
3000 years, something like that.
And so I read it because still they
still talk about chariots and kings and
Queens. Everything. That was the first
sign that you are in jail for a reason.
Gels are corrective institutions
that will correct your,
uh, behavior. That's what
the itching is telling you.
That's what the aging, well, what they
did, the updated, the girls that wrote it,
they updated it to the
modern time. You know, it's,
I think it's Armstrong is the girls that,
there are a couple of girls who wrote it.
It's a big thick book,
but his head and then went
on there and another guy,
Mike, this, this uh, Chicano,
he saw me, he's always a game.
So he's all set for the game. What
would you playing? I said, no,
I'm doing the teaching. I said, do you
want me to do you? And he said, yeah.
So I did his and was very polite not to
read the readings of the other guy and
let him read it first.
And so I did the numbers and I give it
to him and he read it and he just handed
me the book and knew what sat
on his bunk and he just stared.
And so then I read what it said and he,
he, uh, a month before
he lost his wife in,
in child, in a car accident, they
were coming out to visit them
and the [inaudible] said,
you suffered a great misfortune.
Oh,
it was like dead on.
And the itching goes on to tell Ya,
you know what to do and,
and you know, this is, next
month is going to be tough,
this month is going to be good.
You know,
and we see hope for you is like astrology.
It's almost the same.
Well,
I know Terence Mckenna was really into it.
He's really into the each thing and he
thought it was some sort of a map of time.
He was trying to figure out what it was
and how it worked and why can predict
things.
And if you mess with it, it'll, it'll
tell you investing fuck with it.
I like we, we board, you know, sometimes
if you do the Ouija board, same thing.
If you start making it a game,
you know, let's ask it this.
Let's ask dad who's going to
win the race tomorrow on that.
And right away the chain catches
that and knows your real feelings and
intelligent, you know, tell you don't,
don't do that. What do you think it is?
It's a Chinese some methods of divination.
I think what it is,
it's a spiritual way of communicating
this remembering ghost where,
uh, Patrick Swayze had to
learn how to move a coin.
Remember that the spirits,
especially spiritual people,
they're around us.
And so you give them a chance
to communicate with you
because they know all they
will communicate.
And so the itching gives it the
spirits a chance to communicate.
So when you throw a coin,
they know what, what,
what heads or tails or whatever it is,
the number that you need to
read to talk to you. Right.
And that's, that's my theory,
Huh? You gotta try it, man.
Yeah.
I'm,
I'm curious because I do know that many
people have used it to try to figure out
what their life is about and what
they're doing with their lives.
And the weirdest thing about it is they,
they,
they seem to find some real answers in
it and they keep them to themselves.
Yeah.
But the,
the idea that I had heard that made the
most sense was that the way the world
works is not as simple and as easy
as one plus one equals two left,
right, left, right. Walked down the road.
But that there's intention and thought
that also helps formulate our universe.
And what the,
each thing does is it somehow clarifies
intention and thought and clarifies
like the actual,
your actual,
the actual processes going
on in your mind and it,
it quantifies it and puts it into a like,
oh,
a way that you can read your effect on
life and life's effect on you in this.
And then it reads it somehow or another
even though it doesn't make any sense
that, well, it's a method of divination.
It's method of discovering
what's happening. Yeah.
It's a method of communicating
with the spirit world.
You think that's what it is.
Oh, Ghana. And the thing is,
you're getting back to the AI,
the artificial intelligence, uh,
that we already used artificial
intelligence in our lives every day.
Like Alexa is a good
example. That bitch. Yeah,
I love her.
She never
steered me wrong yet. You know, she's
told me, I bet the wrong questions,
but I see this and my theory is that,
that we are,
we,
everybody in the universe wants us
dispirits they want us to be enlightened,
you know,
because the more enlightened we are,
the more we can enjoy what we,
what we're, what we've inherited.
Because when you're born into this
world, [inaudible] you, you've inherited,
you're taking them for granted
kingdom amazing. You've inherited a,
especially in comparison to the
rest of time, all of human history.
This is the greatest time, the greatest
bolster to fortunate. So what I'm saying,
look at us. Look, look, look what
we got now going for us to know.
And how much effort did that take? You
know, it was like being part of a team.
And so when you're ready at Boomi, you're
pushed out in front, you're up there.
And so, you know, our, our duty as, as,
as students is to learn everything we
can learn and to teach whatever we can
teach,
you know?
And that's why there should be no paranoia
because we're not here long enough.
So that being rich or being poor,
it makes any kind of a difference,
you know,
because you know yourself,
I mean w w what do you really need in
this life? Right. What do you really need?
Water, food, companionship.
Love. Yeah. France.
Yeah. Yeah. And something interesting
that you'd like to do. Yeah. Cause I, I,
I've been hanging with billionaires now.
And what have you been doing with them?
You understand your note? You know,
they, they, they like me because I,
I get recognized everywhere I
go. And so, so it sort of, uh,
it's like, uh, you know, walking
around status symbol, famous guy a,
you can get into restaurants and
pitchers and for the most part they're,
they're hardworking, very, you know, like
a lot of burdens being rich,
a lot of burdens and, and the, you know,
it just with me, you know, it's
like, instead of owning a boat,
I'd rather know a guy that owns the bolts
definitely enough to deal with any of
the maintenance. That's
true. I like to be free.
I like to be totally free. Yeah. Yeah.
That's the reality of, I mean, if you
want to have a big, giant crazy business,
you're going to have a lot of employees.
You're gonna have a lot of problems you
have to deal with and you're the last
guy to get paid. Yep. Yeah. And
you're the last guy that goes home.
Everybody else forgets what they're doing
as soon as they walk out the door and
you're, all those problems are in
your, but yeah. Yeah, that's true.
I went through that.
I had to nightclubs at one time,
but I never bothered with
the money part at all.
I just worried about the stage.
The Mike was working in
the US in Vancouver when,
how long ago was this? This was sixties
in the sense that you had nightclubs,
like comedy clubs or like one,
one was an after hours,
sorta like a jazz dance bottle
club and it was given to me.
It's here, there again, you know, hey, Hey
Tommy, me, you went to club and I said,
sure. The Guy bought
give you a club. Yeah,
well he bought a building and back in.
Then back in the day,
there was a steak house in
the basement. He says, man,
the chairs pay rent when
you can. What? So I went in,
what was this guy's deal?
He owned buildings healing.
Most people that own buildings don't be
giving them away. Oh yeah. All they do,
they rent free rent.
You saw him all the time.
You can get a years free rent just because
they want to get someone in the only
blend that you get it.
You get it going.
And seeing as soon as we
start being successful,
we were paying $500 a month
rent. So he got, you're going.
So we made a ton of money in there
and that's where I got the bands.
You know,
that's where I honed my skills as
a musician and singer and all that.
And then I got offered
another club because it was
going under and it was a dine
and dance club in Chinatown.
And I thought, yeah,
make a great strip club. And so, so we,
we took it over to the Shanghai junk,
turned it into a strip club,
Vancouver's first strip club.
And then you were the
proprietor of Vancouver's first
ever first trip come from
this one. And in fact we
did a, uh, in fact we did a,
uh, a midnight mass at a church. Uh,
I think we had the stripper dancing
at the church, but not stripping.
She kept your clothes on. She danced.
That's appropriate. Yeah. Yeah.
You got to you, there's a line. When did
you start getting into the live shows?
Well when, uh, I got
fired from Motown, uh,
because I had to get a green card and
nobody had Motown knew with a green card
was, and so I had to miss a Gig, uh, to,
to get my green card.
I got the green card and they
came back and I got fired.
And so then Barry Gordy found out about
it. He said, Oh, you're not fired. I said,
I think I'll stay fired. I want to be
at Berry Gordy. I don't work for one.
And so then came out to,
uh,
out to La and tried to live on
the beach and be a songwriter.
But then my clubs were calling
me because they needed help.
So I went back and I turned the strip
club into an improvisational club.
So we're doing naked.
Improv was great man.
All the girls and then they were actors.
There are strippers.
Once I turned them into actresses,
there were a lot cheaper and there are
not more beautiful. The, the target,
they did skits and then they would take
off their clothes when they had to, uh,
be it within, within, you know, the, the
script. And that's where I met Cheech,
cause we had a street guy in the street,
guys,
wife found out what he was doing and
you can hold them away. And then she,
she came onboard as a straight guy.
And then when, when everything,
Vancouver, Vancouver, yeah. But
teaches an La guy, right? Yeah.
He was up there in case of
Viet Cong attacked from Alaska.
So he was hiding even from the draft.
Well, not really. He will not really,
it was trying to stay out of the way.
Let's put it out. And then, then he,
he had a sneak back in [inaudible]
from [inaudible]. Yeah.
But it was easy coming
into La from Canada.
He just showed someone else's Id and they
said dog one and back in the day. Yeah.
We're all slots. Slipperier yeah. And
that's, so that's why I'm saying I,
I'm so blessed, you know, because
everything, the universe, you know,
and it was from the teaching start,
uh,
one of the guitar players turned me
onto the each thing back then. And,
and my reading was perfection.
You're going to be,
everything's perfect.
You're going to really do well.
And then Cheech and Chong and
all that stuff happened and,
and you guys are touring again? Yeah. All
right. How long have you been born again?
When did you guys get back together? Boy,
eight Oh eight yeah. Hold 11 years. Yeah.
How crazy is that? That that's 11 years
ago. That doesn't seem like 11 years ago.
I know you say, oh wait. It's like, oh,
just happened. And you're like, oh no,
it's 2019 so almost 2020 no,
I know that the train keeps the
ruling, dude. It never stops.
What does this Jamie,
Bobby Taylor and the Vancouvers well,
that's me.
That's you? Yeah. How old were you there?
23 Bobby Taylor and the Vancouvers twice.
I kind of sunglasses off.
Yeah,
they did. Even back then. Wow.
Bobby Taylor and the Vancouvers.
That's the motel on sunset strip.
Is that you with the yellow jacket?
Which ones? Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's you. Yeah, that's me.
Wow,
that's crazy. And then we,
we went over to England,
met Jimi Hendrix, whoa.
And changed our lives.
This is where we look when we went over
there and where you can bag long hair.
Everybody wear different clothes.
Wow.
Now when you went from this to comedy?
Yeah.
Like how did you make that leap?
Well,
nobody really knew that
I could talk. You know,
I was in a black band, so everybody else,
you know, how was the guitar player?
So you know, I had nothing to say
other than Allen, the club, you know,
and no one knew that. No one knew that
I was always a backup guitar player.
When I got into comedy wells was
doing what happened. I at hired,
when I turned the strip club into
a Improv, a clo improvisation club,
I hired the act we already had,
which was a black tap dancer
named taps Harris and Jenia,
a black singer. And they
had a band. And so I,
the first skit I had tapped it,
the first kid was about a Pajama party
that all the strippers were having at
their house after.
And so they all change into their pajamas
and in their little ladies and that
was very sexy. And then taps
came, comes by after the show,
you know, so-called, and,
and they say, hey tabs,
do that number that you did a on the show.
And so taps,
first time you ever tap danced,
you know,
in front of a live audience
because usually he was just an MC.
So he did his tap dance and then it was
so good that everybody wanted her dawn
card. So they made them do an
encore. He quit that night.
Really? Yeah. It was too
hard work, man. That's,
he was hired to just do the Lolo.
And so the doorman who lit
English guy named Dave.
And so I said, Dave, I need
a, an Mc, you know, he said,
well, I'll do it if you do it.
And so I, I, okay. And so we became,
Dave was my first partner
and so we started,
we had long hair where they
hippies. And so we, we, we were,
we did a lot of hippies and Qa jokes,
you know,
tits and ass jokes and uh,
and then,
then we had a guitar player named gate
alarm. He, he wrote the, the, our big hit,
you know, that your eight,
my eye, he wrote the music.
And so gay was this incredible
guitarist and he could do all,
but he was very funny, funny, funny
guy. And so we wrote a skit, you know,
where,
where you were tortured the audience,
they're all biker mostly don't come to
a strip bar. You didn't bikers in that.
And so the first act we had it because
when we turned it into a theater company,
we attracted all the theater. People
all know performers, you know,
there was a stage, oh boy, we'll go
work there. And so we had a mime artist.
And so we opened the show with them.
I am artist and Gaye
playing classical guitar.
He's playing this classical
guitar now this is a strip joint.
And all they're hardened bikers are
sitting around waiting for naked girls to
come out. And here comes, here
comes a mime artist, you know,
so pretend he's, he's picking flowers
and smelling the mood, the tone,
the prancing around the stage and
the, so the bikers sat through that, you
know, the neighbor yelling things like,
hey Elvis,
their remarks were that funny.
And then send the, Dave would come
out and Dave's very funny looking guy.
He looks like a, it looks like an
Improv actor and they come out and he,
and he sings this horrible side.
I dream of Jeannie with
the light brown hair.
Jeannie is my favorite wire hair terrier.
And then just when the bikers
are getting ready to revolt,
I opened, I kicked the door open,
we had doors on the back, you know,
and I kicked the door open and shirtless.
My hair's messed up and I got a rolled
up newspaper and I walk over to David
Goal.
What kind of fucking song is that?
I beat him to death with this
newspaper and the bikers to explode.
The whole joint just exploded, you
know, laughter. Because we had,
we created that tension
that long and then release.
The release was like as a roar and
then the word went out, boom. And that,
that place was packed almost every night.
Wow.
What a weird world that must've been back
then. They'll give us the city works.
There we are.
There's days that Turkle sexy
at the Shang. Hi. There's
the far are right.
Wow. That's Cheech. That's
crazy. That's cheat.
That's Dave. That's me. Wow. Without
a goatee. And that's the, my
Martha says Ian, the mime artist,
and it's windy, Maureen and surely. Wow.
What a weird world. Is it
crazy looking at that? Oh yeah.
Wow. Memories. Huh? Wow.
That was the first a strip joint
starting Tuesday. Yeah. Yeah.
While the police were there. And when
did you start doing albums with Cheech?
Cheech 71 how'd that all take place?
Well,
we came down there and 70 and we struggled
with all the places that we could,
we could work. Then we started
being a regular at the troubadour.
They had hootenanny night, Sunday night.
What does that mean? What's hootenanny?
Those learning is when the folk singers,
we'd get on stage and singers sing a
song hootenanny hootenanny the hootenanny
night. And so all the
singers would sing, you know?
And so we would get up and do comedy
and of course we became regulars,
you know, in fact the tubular would phone
us up and say, are you guys come in?
Because they had a lot of requests.
And how did it transpire?
This weed based comedy? Well it was the
only thing that worked in this audience.
The we'd see when we're, the
city works with TNA, you know.
But when we got down here,
we had a go right for the stoners because
that was what was going on, you know?
And so we played a a club
in Receda Irma hotel.
It was sort of this call
and it was owned by a crazy,
it was a big fan. He saw
us work somewhere. And so
he hired us for two nights.
And in the first night,
personally we had to do two shows,
but it was a dance club.
And so the dancers had to stop dancing,
sit down and watch us to a show and,
and it was not a good combination.
So the first show didn't go very well
because we're doing TNA stuff and just
didn't go over.
And so the second show teach and I
got together and I teach, c'mon man,
you're from here.
There must be a character you can do.
And the night before that we
were standing outside and uh,
this low rider pulls up and you go,
hey man,
tell me how to get the receipt boulevard.
And she says, Oh, you're on it. He goes,
oh, thanks man. And he's
overweight and was that character?
And Cheech says, yeah, well
yeah, we can do that character.
And then I showed them that
the carbon that's an old black,
a comedian chilled me,
Sir Pineapple,
you show me this whole taking a girl out
on a date and he just make the car up
here by pretending to wash it whacks,
you know,
just do the mine in the car would appear.
And then Cheech got in the car and
he's driving and then he goes, hey,
red frequent or ride man.
And then I would come out and we'd do our,
our skits and,
and went over it really well as soon as
we started doing, you know, weed and,
and pills and stuff.
Everybody related.
So you feel like you had that and then
he just ran with it? Oh yeah. Yeah.
And then we just improved,
improved, improved, improved.
And so when we met Lou Adler Saws and
we never thought about doing a record
until we went to meet him in his office
and he's got gold records are all over
the place. And we said, yeah, we
can do, we'll do a record. You know,
I was a big Lenny Bruce fan anyway,
because when I got high the first time I,
the guy gave me a joint
and a Lenny Bruce Record.
So I studied that record for months.
And so that was ingrained in my head.
And so then when we started doing,
the first bit we did was an accident and
Cheech got locked outside the mixdown
room though we were on Labrea,
you know the old Charlie Chapman studio
and it was the little courtyard that
where the sun was beating down was like
noon and it was hot and teaches a method
actor. And he had, he put on
all the costumes, you know,
they could get into character.
So he's got all these costumes,
Ziney knocks on the door and I was
working the tape recorder and I,
and when he knocked out,
I looked up at the door and I didn't
see if the needle moved or not.
And so when he not,
I didn't answer.
And then you knocked again and I saw the
needle moved and so I said, who is it?
And I was supposed to just
open the door and let him in.
And so there was a pause. It's a
meme there, it's me, let me in.
Come on man. So then there's that where
Dave's not here came from it. So I waited,
then he knocked again in a
long pause. The pause. The,
who is it? And he's getting mad. Come
on man, it's me. I think the cop saw me.
You come on open up, you know they went
into character then. Then I'll just wait,
wait, wait. It's way
for me to open the door.
Then he knocked again and w finally
goes, it's me, Dave, man, Dave.
I said, Dave. And he goes,
yeah, I go to Dave's not here.
He blew it, kicking the doors, screaming,
opened the door and you almost punched
me. And, but I said, listen, listen,
listen week. We played it
back and then Lou heard it.
We recorded it.
Not as funny,
but we recorded it and next
day it was all over America.
Cheech and Chong was born.
Wow.
And then how long after that you
start doing movies? Seven years. 78
we started doing the movies because
I got tired of going to Australia.
Did you guys get accused of promoting pot?
Oh yeah.
Like did you get like accused like you,
you guys are a bad influence on the youth.
And what was that like?
There was nothing really, there's
more publicity basically, you know,
you know, it's just people, you know,
you know what really got
what really I noticed anyway.
It was the, uh, the comedy establishment,
the committee in the second city,
all those guys,
they hated us, really hated us. Why?
Except Bellucci Belushi was the only one
that loved us cause Belushi was young
enough that he heard our
records and it influenced him.
But these other guys like,
um, uh, what's his name?
I can't even think of his name now. Maybe
it's better. I don't even name them.
But they, they, Howard Hesseman, he,
he was one of the committee members,
you know, and, and you know,
Wk Erp and Cincinnati shore.
He was a big,
and I got influenced by him big time
because I saw him doing the committee in,
in San Francisco and they had a top
notch, a, an Improv group there.
And they were incredible.
And that's where I got the inspiration
to go up and turn the Strip club into a
improvisational club because
I love Improv. Why didn't
those guys like you? What,
what was the,
cause we were successful.
We took what they were doing
and took it out of the,
that snotty CEO to CEO to,
you know,
I'm so, I'm so evolved
theatrically, you know,
that who does records, you know, that
kind of thing. And next thing you know,
teach skirts were bad back then. Well,
the ended up trying to do a record,
but they had, they had no clue. You
know, like, see I'm a fighter man.
I've been in the trenches forever.
You know,
I've been playing black clubs
as long as I can remember.
And so I seen a lot of humor, a lot
of the standup comics, you know,
red foxes, a real good friend of mine.
Did you ever do as comedy club his? Yeah.
Yeah. Ever hear those Richard Pryor
tapes from the Red Fox comedy club?
They would record him like doing his
work outs, outs, fucking amazing stuff.
Amazing. Oh yeah. Richard Richard
was a big fan. Big Fan. Now see,
we had fans like that,
but when she should,
I did the comedy store after up in smoke,
we broke up with Lou and we were broke.
We had a hit movie with no money.
Nothing. Kaylee, what happened? They
stole your money with Lou. Yeah.
Who was Lou Lou Adler. Okay. And he's
the producer and director of up in smoke.
And although I wrote, wrote it
and directed it, most of it,
and especially the ending, uh,
I, I directed, I like, again,
like again, like I said before, I'm
not into into the money part of it.
And how will you guys broke while we
weren't getting any money from our law
because we had to stop
touring because of the movie.
And so we had no touring money
coming in. Right. And so,
and then we got paid pump, you
know, a little bit on the movie,
but nothing compared to what we
were making on the road. And uh,
what does a hugely successful
movie. Right. Totally. Totally.
But that's the way it is. I just to just,
they took all the money. Yeah. Yeah.
You did. I mean, we got, uh, we get dribs
and drabs at the end of the accounting,
the Hollywood accounting. Yeah. At
the end of the period of, you know,
when you forget when you're gone onto
something else and then you get a check.
Oh that's nice.
Yeah.
But so Cheech and I went to the comedy
store to get our act together and Richard
Pryor helped us ought to stage.
We had about five sold out shows.
Pauly shore was a little guy up in the
light boots and watch knows cause he was
too young to be in the, in the
crowd. And as we walked up the stage,
the first night,
Richard's there,
he held out his hand and was the
greatest compliment ever. Wow.
That must have been incredible. It was.
Listen man, you had an amazing life.
You really have. The itching
was correct. Oh yeah, totally.
It's worked out incredible.
I got to find a professional.
You got to get them to come
in and read us the Chang.
Someone who really knows their
shit. Do it. It's easy. Read it.
There's one called uh, arms, the Armstrong
version. I'll text it to you. Okay.
And uh, just read it yet. All right. Hey,
listen to biking follow instructions.
Anybody? Well, listen brother, it
was a pleasure having you on, uh,
tell people about your weed. Charles'
choice. We're going to get it.
Dispensaries everywhere. Is there
a website? Yeah, there's websites.
There is actually the fun is finding
Chung's choice because we are so,
uh,
elite as far as the testing in the
purity of the product that it's very rare
that certain dispensary's habit
and a lot of dispensaries don't.
And they'll try to sell you something
else, but don't settle for less man.
Chung's choices.
The Best Tennis Ladies and gentlemen,
it's a way better than teachers privates.
How dare you? No know teachers. I mean,
it's okay, but it's Mexican, you know?
Well, thank you, sir. Thanks for coming
on here, man. It's always a pleasure.
My pleasure, Joan honor. Thank
you, Tommy Chong. These gentlemen.